and it is a good year to start building
the personal savings the new tax plan is
now in effect and Americans at most
income levels will eventually get some
relief the nonpartisan Tax Policy Center
estimates taxes on the average household
will be cut by about $1,600
for middle income earners making between
forty nine thousand and eighty six
thousand dollars a year that translates
into an extra nine hundred dollars CBS
News business analyst Jill Schlesinger
is here good morning good morning so do
most according to surveys do most people
realize that they're going to get a tax
break and know what to do with it
unfortunately no most people don't see
it and I think it has to do with that
number you said about the nine hundred
dollars over the course of a year
because when you break that down you get
paid every other week or every week it
may be you know maybe 75 bucks a month
and that's a weird amount because it's
just enough where you actually could do
something great with it unfortunately
it's a small enough amount that if you
don't figure out how to capture the
money you might spend it so the first
thing that every certified financial
planner will tell people is set up some
system to automatically capture that
money so go check the pay stub go check
your bank account if you got direct
deposit set something up get that money
out of your hands before you spend it
put it into savings bump up your
retirement savings start putting more
money down on that credit card debt that
you carry do something and make it
automatic tax day is approaching April
15th a lot of people are already
thinking about tax returns and fingers
cross eyes cross legs and out toes cross
that you're getting money back what's
the fastest way to get the money well
you know the IRS says about 70 percent
of taxpayers will get a refund last of
your seventy percent last year the
average refund was amazing almost twenty
nine hundred dollars so the best way to
get that money back quickly is to file
electronically and file early and we
talked about this in years past where we
want you to file early also because
there's a lot of tax fraud out there
especially in light of last year's
Equifax data breach filing early helps
you stay ahead of the fraudsters get
that money back IRS has great tools IRS
to go they've got mobile apps you can
check on your refund most people who get
refunds get them within 21 days of file
your necklace is hitting the microphone
oh dear just pull it down sorry
all right Jill do people so they're
those people who don't know they're
gonna get a tax break but then are there
others who spend it already before they
ever get it yes Gail sitting right next
to you no I mean well yes and
unfortunately some people will say I
know I'm going to get a tax refund so
I'm gonna run up my credit card bill in
advance so obviously we don't want you
to do that if you do get a tax refund
again it's a good way for you to boost
your savings if you get a tax refund
this year don't count on it necessarily
for next year wait to see one full year
of that new tax law in place to see how
you stand I wish I would have met you
when I was 25 no no asking for a lot of
restraint from people - that's right
thanks a lot